طائره امريكيه حققت انتصارات اكثر من اي
طائره اخرى صنعتها الولايات المتحده في
فتره الحرب العالميه الثانيه استخدمت في
عمليات الهجوم البريه وحققت هيمنه جويه
كبيره في معارك الجو جو المقاتله الهجوميه
اي الصاعقه باللغه العربيه
حلقت مقاتله للمره الاولى في العام 1941
كما خضعت لعدد من التعديلات جعلتها اكبر
واثقل مقاتله بمحرك واحد خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
زودت هذه المقاتله بثمانيه مدافع رشاشه
كما كان لديها قدره على حمل قنبلتين او
اكثر هذا طبعا بحسب وزن هذه القنابل على
الرغم من تعدد مهام افندمبولت الا انها
غالبا ما كانت تستخدم في توفير حمايه
للقاذفات في مهام متوسطه المدى اضافه الى
اعتبارها من اقوى المقاتلات في المواجهات
الجويه على ارتفاعات عاليه من ابرز ما
تميز به هذه المقاتله هو هيكلها القوي
الذي مكنها من مواصله مهامها حتى بعد
اصابتها خلال الاشتباكات الجويه بل
والعوده لقاعدتها بسلامه استخدمت بريطانيا
هذه المقاتله ضد اليابان في معارك جنوب
شرق اسيا كما لعبت ايضا دورا بارزا في
تدمير تحصينات الجيش اليابانيه تم انتاج
اكثر من 15 الف مقاتله من هذا اقراص وظلت
في الخدمه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى العام 1954